foreign
I am mayank and welcome to Simply learn
today we will take you through the hands
of lab demo of how you can create a mask
detection application using Python and
machine learning before we start I hope
this screen is clearly visible and the
audio is fine if yes please type in yes
if there are any issues do let us know
in the chat section so that we can
resolve them I'm repeating again before
we start I hope this screen is clearly
visible and the audio is fine if yes
please type in yes if there are any
issues do let us know in the chat
section so that we can resolve them
let's wait for some more minutes to let
other the people join until then let me
tell you guys that we have regular
updates on multiple Technologies if you
are a tech geek on a continuous hunt for
the latest technological Trends then
consider getting subscribed to our
YouTube channel and press that Bell icon
to never miss any update from Simply
learn I'm repeating again let me tell
you guys that we have regular updates on
multiple Technologies if you are a
techie in a continuous hunt for the
latest technological Trends then
consider getting subscribed to our
YouTube channel and press that Bell icon
to never miss any update from Simply
learn
great I think we can get started so in
today's session we will go through the
what is object detection is after that
we will create a mass detection
application using opencv Python and
machine learning we will perform
different function and create an amazing
application using different python
libraries before we move on to the
programming part let's discuss what
object detection is first and proceed
further for the same so what is object
detection
a computer vision technique called
object detection is used to find
occurrence of objects in pictures or
movies
object detection algorithms frequently
use machine learning or deep learning to
generate useful results
humans can quickly identify and pinpoint
objects of interest when viewing photos
or videos
using a computer object detection aims
to simulate this intelligence
so moving forward so dear Learners if
you want to upskill your AI and machine
learning skills so give a chance to
simpler and professional certificate
program in Ai and machine learning which
comes completion certificate and
in-depth knowledge of AI and machine
learning check this course detail from
the description box below
so here is one question for you guys I
will give you one minute for this you
can comment or give your answer in the
chat section so I can see if the answers
given by you are right or wrong
so I'm repeating again here is one
question for you I will give you exactly
one minute for this you can comment or
you can give your answer in the chat
section so I can see if the answers
given by you are right or wrong okay so
the question is
all keywords in pythons are
capitalized lowercase uppercase none
so I'm starting timer of one minute just
type your answers in the comment section
or in the chat section do let me know
your answers
I kindly ask that everyone take part in
this to make this live session exciting
so I'm starting the timer of one minute
all keywords in Python are in capitalize
lowercase uppercase or none
let us know your answer in the comment
section below
I kindly ask that everyone take part in
this to make this life session exciting
40 seconds remaining
all keywords in Python are in capitalize
lowercase uppercase or none
do let me know your answer in the
comment section or in the chat section
I kindly ask that everyone take part in
this to make this live session exciting
15 seconds more
all keywords in Python are in capitalize
lowercase uppercase or none
five seconds more
okay time up so after the allotted time
has passed Those Who provided the
correct response will receive a response
and those Who provided incorrect
response will receive one
so now let's move to our programming
part to create Mass detection using
opencv python
so first we will open command prompt to
write a command to open jupyter notebook
so here we will write Jupiter
notebook
then press enter
so it will take some time yeah
so this is the landing page of Jupiter
notebook and here we have to new then
python 3.
so this is how the jupyter notebook UI
look likes so at first we will import
some major libraries of python which
help in creating a mass detection system
so here I will write import
CV2 comma OS
and press enter then I will give the
path then data path
to assume
C
and Slash
users
and Slash
SLP
zero nine three seven five
and Slash
desktop
and Slash
and face
mask
detection
then slash
data set
okay
so here it will be slash my bad sorry
and Slash
okay let's look fine
so here I will write categories
equals to OS Dot
list
directory this dir
then I will assign data underscore path
then I will create some labels
equals to
here I will write
I will write here I
four
i n
range
then here I will give length
of
categories
yeah
then press enter Then here I will write
label
then protect directory
pursue
directory then
zip then categories
comma labels
so here I will write print
then label directory
okay then I will print
categories
then I will print labels
okay then press enter
yeah
so here CV means capturing video the CV2
function in opencv can read video video
capture by using pass zero as a function
parameter we can access our webcam
we may pass rtsp URL in the function
parameter to capture CCTV footage which
is quite helpful for video analysis then
OS this this OS module the OS module in
Python has function for adding and
deleting folders retrieving their
contents changing the directory locating
the current directory and more before
you can communicate with the underlying
operation system you must import the OS
module
and this OS list directory
to retrieve a list of all files and
folders in the given directory use
Python OS dot list directory method the
list of files are directory in the
current working directory will be
returned if no data is specified
then label
the the TK enter widget class called a
label is used to show text or an image
the user views the label they cannot be
interact with it so moving forward I
will write code so just stay with me
after that I will explain you line wise
okay
so here
I will write
that
image underscore size
plus two hundred
then I will create two classes data
then Target
okay
arrays
then I will write here for category
in categories
folder
underscore
but
equals to OS dot path
then dot join
then data
underscore path
comma
category
okay then IMG
image names equals to OS dot list
directory then folder path
just stay with me I will explain you
line wise
okay so here I will write for
IMG name
in IMG
names
IMG underscore path
equals to OS dot path
Dot
join
then I will write here folder
I repeat
I repeat so here we write folder
underscore path
then
IMG underscore name
so IMG equals to CV2
dot I am read
then IMG underscore path
so here I will write try
that gray
equals to
CV2
dot CVT
and capital c color
then IMG comma CV2
Dot
then color
then underscore B gr to RGB
okay
so I will go for the gray one
CVT color pgr
to RGB yeah
so I will write here this size okay not
in capital letter G size
equals to CV2
dot resize
then Gray
comma IMG
size
comma
I am Jason
why this two mg size because like length
and like width and breadth would be
shame
like 100 so press enter
so I will write Theta Dot
append
then resized
then Target
dot append
then label
then directory
of category
okay
so
I will write here except
exception
as e
so here I will print
and
exception
comma e
okay then press enter let's see there
should be no error
so it is loading let's wait
okay no adder
so image size should be like 100 by 100
so that is why I wrote here 100 the
enemy size 100 by 100.
and I made two arrays like for one for
data then one for targets
so
this for this great question cbt.cvt
color image so converting the image into
grayscale okay then this line resize
equals to CB2 dot resize gray IMG
so resizing the grayscale into like 100
by 100 since we need a fixed common size
for all the images in the data set okay
then this target a DOT append label
directory so appending the image like
and the label categories into the list
list what is list data set
so like for the last print exception e
so if any exception raised the exception
will be printed here and the pass to the
next image okay
so moving forward let's import numpy and
save this data and the target okay so I
will write here
import
numpy
as NP
right
then I will write here data
equals to
NP dot array
then again data
by 255
.0
okay
then again data
equals to NP Dot
reshape
then data
comma
data
dot shape
then zero
comma mg size
comma IMG size
comma 1.
okay
then press enter Then for Target
let me put those just like this then
Target equals to NP dot array
then Target
okay
okay
so here I will write from
Keras Dot
doodles
import
and putas
okay
so here I will write new underscore
Target
equals to
NP underscore utils
dot two
underscore categories
categorical I guess categorical
then Target
okay
then press enter
so here I will save NP dot save
this data
comma data
okay and NP dot safe
this target
comma new Target
okay
so press enter
here
so numpy Nampa is a python Library used
for working with Diaries it also has a
function for working with in the domain
of linear algebra and matrices it is an
open source project and you can use it
freely numpy stand for numerical python
and this Keras
a python interface for artificial
neutral network is provided by the open
source software package known as Keras
the tensorflow library interface is
provided by the Keras a number of
backends were supported by KRS up until
version 2.3 including tensorflow
Microsoft cognitive
so this is the part of the data
processing this all this part of the
data processing
so let me write here data
pre-processing free processor
so the data preprocessing part is done
now we will create the another file of
this python for the training CNN CNN
means convocational neural network okay
test data
comma
train underscore Target
comma test underscore
Target
because you train
underscore split
then we will split on data and Target
comma yes size should be
0.1
okay so now I will give presenter okay
train speed train split is not defined
okay
it is strain
test split
yeah
so now I will write checkpoint
request to model
foreign
model
I repeat so here I will write model
comma
epoch
than 0 3D
dot model
okay
so here I have to write comma monitor
equals to Value loss
underscore
loss
comma
bubbles
equals to zero
comma save
best
only
question
through
drama mode
equals two more should be Auto
okay
then I will press enter
then here I will write history
it goes to model
Dot
with
to train
underscore data
comma
okay chain
underscore Target
comma
apoc address equals to 20
comma callbacks
callback is equals to
checkpoint
comma validation
validation underscore split
equals to 0.2 the best ratio okay
so let me press enter okay there is one
error model dot fit code 10x
okay this should be a spelling mistake
epoch
pochs
pursue 20
.
foreign
then monitor
goes to Value loss
and
propose equals to zero
save best only equal to true then more
Okay so
here I have to write
maybe it will so it will take some time
to go till 20 okay so it will download
one by one
so we will wait
for a while
so the model checkpoints are completed
so here I will write print
then model
dot evaluate
okay
here I will write test underscore data
comma test
underscore Target
then press enter
okay so I hope you guys understand till
here if you have any question or any
query regarding any code just put as in
comments our team will surely provide
you the correct solution okay so moving
forward we will do we will create
another file for detecting mask okay so
I will go here and then
new file
python
so I will write here detecting
okay
yeah
so I will import some libraries here
here as dot models
import
load
models
we will import
CV2
and we will import
numpy
as NP
so press enter
okay number as anything
okay so press enter
so what I will do I will write here
model equals to load underscore model
then
okay
Keras model from gas cannot import name
Okay so
it is model only
yeah
so here I will add model equals to load
model
so I will write a model
017
dot model
okay
okay
so here I will write face underscore
classifier
equals to CB2
Dot
Cascade
Cascade classifier
so this is one file for frontal phase
default
so you can find this file on the
description box below so I will write
here
our Cascade
underscore
until
face
underscore default
dot XML
okay
so source
equals to
CV2
Dot
video
capture
zero it will open our camera
so labels
underscore directory
question
0
mask
and one for
no mask
okay
so colors
directory equals to
like no mask for red and mask for green
okay so here we're at zero
then 0 comma 2
55 comma 0
then again comma for one there should be
0 comma 0 comma 251.
okay
so I hope you guys understand till here
so if you have any question or any query
regarding any code so just put as in
comments our team will surely provide
you the correct solution
so
the code is written
so let me run this for this first I have
to like
so first I have to close my this person
on screen camera
so the code is running fine
now it is showing no Mass
now it is showing us
so I hope you guys understand till here
if you have any queries any question
regarding any code just put as his
comment our team will shortly provide
you the correct solution I hope you guys
must have understood how you can create
mask detection system using opencv
python if you have any queries you can
ask in the comment section below our
team will respond you as soon as
possible and if you want this full code
just comment for the same thank you so
much for being here if you enjoyed this
video please do subscribe to our YouTube
channel and give a like to this video
thank you and keep learning
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here